for a long time we assume the solar
system ended where the planets ended but
the discovery of the Kuiper belt in the
90s doubled the reach of the sun's
influence and let scientists ask could
it reach further turns out it does much
further and we wouldn't be here if it
didn't
if you put a Geiger counter in this room
it would click if you put a Geiger
counter up in space it would click a lot
more it's detecting a deadly form of
radiation called cosmic rays cosmic rays
are essentially subatomic particles like
the nuclei of helium atoms and protons
and electrons that are zipping through
space at almost the speed of light and
these can travel across great distances
hundreds thousands of light-years and it
turns out they hit us here on earth
cosmic rays blast out of exploding stars
deep in the galaxies and they're
incompatible with life they can rip out
electrons they can in fact change the
chemical configuration of cells causing
mutations they can ultimately kill you
if the earth were continually blasted by
cosmic rays without any protection it's
not clear that advanced forms of life
could survive but very few of the cosmic
rays end of us hit us
clearly something out there is
protecting us from the full onslaught of
cosmic rays from the universe it's our
son creating a deflector shield reaching
eight point seven billion miles out in
space using its solar wind
when you think of wind do you think of
the air of the earth you're moving
through your hair the solar wind is
nothing like that it's actually a stream
of high-energy particles coming off the
Sun things like hydrogen and it's
substantial it's billions of tons every
second some parts of the solar wind are
going as fast as about two million miles
an hour it can pack quite a wallop
the wallop blows bias here on earth
because our planet's magnetic field
deflects it away the solar wind doesn't
just stop at the earth it's out in space
it keeps going it blows past the inner
planets it blows past the outer planets
Jupiter Saturn Uranus Neptune and keeps
going it also blows past the Kuiper belt
carrying the sun's magnetic field three
and a half billion miles beyond and
creates a huge defensive shield around
the solar system called the heliosphere
the solar wind is blowing a bubble
around our solar system the Sun is like
a big mother that literally creates a
bubble of charged particles and
associated magnetic fields that protect
us from cosmic rays coming from outside
the solar system the incoming cosmic
rays hit the outgoing solar wind and
most are deflected away into space
without this standoff deep in space we'd
be wiped out